earlier I told you David became Goliath
Goliath is trying to become David
Goliath is using the formula David their
revenues are going higher profits go
going lower because they're reinvesting
but here's what's taking place guess
what happens when you become the biggest
the best the baddest what happens when
you become the biggest the best the
baddest so you start beating people
people that have more experience than
you people that are more educated than
you people that were bigger than you
people that you should have never been
what happens when you do that you start
creating enemies and guess who's
creating a lot of enemies our dear
friends at Amazon they're creating a lot
of enemies but guess what's happening
with Amazon creating a lot of enemies a
lot of people are fall in love in love
with Walmart like hoop at like Google
Google is saying hey Amazon we don't
like you we don't like you we don't we
don't want to help Google you know we
don't want to help Amazon so Google is
saying no problem you're competing we're
gonna help your enemy because an enemy
of an enemy is a friend okay
an enemy of an enemy is a friend and
Google is coming and saying look why
don't you sell some of your products on
our website Google has never done this
before why are they doing this because
they want to empower these guys so
what's gonna be taking place right now
moving forward here's what I can tell
you if you are looking at these two
juggernauts going at it together who's
gonna win this heavyweight matchup a lot
of people are saying 100% Amazon a lot
of people are saying 100% Amazon but
those who are saying 100% Amazon behind
closed doors don't really know what's
going on those behind closed doors who
know what's going on are saying I don't
know I think these guys are pretty crazy
as well they have a lot of capital they
got a lot of money they got a lot of
physical stores people want to go to
stores and buy food right now they don't
want to go tomorrow what if these guys
use their stores as a fulfillment center
yes they have 75 fulfillment centers and
they got 42 but if you really think
about it Walmart's really got 11341
hundred twenty thousand products that
they can stale but it's the hundred and
twenty thousand most popular products
that you want to buy right they have
that so what if you can go online
and order your whole your groceries your
milk your food whatever 20 minutes later
is delivered to your house what if you
could do that because Walmart's only ten
miles away from you 90 percent what if
they could do that
that's dangerous over here because these
guys are trying to get more but you know
yeah what he call it the drones they're
trying to get all this technology set up
to try to compete with these guys but
it's not a done deal yet for those that
think Amazon's gonna crush them it is
not done Delia look I'm telling you
Vegas odds is still on Amazon side I'm
not telling you it's 5050 odds
absolutely not Amazon has the favor
Amazon currently is Goliath but if
Walmart starts thinking wiring working
innovative being creative like David
like David like these guys were David at
one point this could be a very
interesting very interesting heavyweight
fight taking place the next five 10 15
years that you and I get to witness I
mean you and I get to watch the CC this
taking place well we saw Ali Frazier
you know we saw Holyfield Tyson we saw
some good fights Fury Wilder done that
this is a real heavyweight fight because
this is 650,000 juggernaut going against
2.2 million juggernaut so before you say
Amazon's gonna kill everybody know that
a lot of Amazon's enemies behind closed
doors are now helping these guys beat
these guys so we're gonna see what's
gonna happen so I want to hear from you
if you think it's gonna be Amazon
comment below if you think it's gonna be
Walmart comment below and I told you how
to PDF for you the way to get your PDF
if you're in the States send me a text
at three one zero three four zero one
one three two we will send you the PDF
three one zero three four zero one one
three two if you're not in the States
click on a link below subscribe to our
newsletter we'll send you the PDF as
well and if you enjoyed this video I got
two other videos I want you to watch one
of the videos is a speech I give a
keynote I gave titled think like a Grand
Master entrepreneur it tells you moves
people make I think it got like a
million views in a span of a couple
months if you haven't watch I highly
recommend you watching this the other
one is a video I did of seeing what's
more valuable
Elon Musk or Tesla should you be banking
on Elon Musk or should you be back
get on Tesla and some of the strategies
I give behind closed doors that test
that Elon Musk is doing that maybe not a
lot of people are paying attention to so
if you want to watch just keno click
over here if you want to watch the Elon
Musk vs Tesla video click over here and
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye